bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur
arte france comment est ce que vous
voyez l'arrivée de cette application
stop qu'ovide avec beaucoup de défiance
en termes de libertés publiques puisque
il y a plusieurs sujets qui se posent en
droit d'abord si celui de l'adhésion
volontaire de nos concitoyens à cette
application c'est à dire que pour
consentir à un abandon de ses libertés
pour nommer les choses il faut que le
consentement soit à tout le moins libre
et éclairé or là nous interrogions nos
concitoyens dans un moment de grandes
affiches étaient et par conséquent le
consentement n'est ni libre ni éclairé
la deuxième chose de savoir à qui seront
confiées les contentieux on est là dans
une politique bureaucratique sans
intervention du juge judiciaire qui est
le seul bon garant donc si vous voulez
cette extension de la police
administrative qui est une tendance de
chef depuis un peu moins d'une dizaine
d'années a matière à inquiéter la bo 4
je suis quels sont les risques
très concrètement vous voyez un danger
pour la vie privée et l'accès aux
données également exactement alors
d'abord l'accès aux données n'est
absolument pas bien sécurisé vous savez
que chaque fois que vous télécharger une
mise à jour de votre application sur
votre téléphone portable
les mises à jour de vos applications
c'est pour corriger les défauts de
sécurité
vous savez que la hache à gap où il ya
quelques années on a dévoilé le nom de
tous les malades du sida c'est un hacker
qui a voulu se venger d'un hôpital et
les noms des 14 mille patients atteints
de cette maladie
donc si vous voulez la sécurité des
données personnelles dans une matière
qui touche au secret médical
ces derniers secrets qui est consacré
par la loi n'est absolument pas un gars
entier par cette application et on
risque d'avoir des démenti cinglant aux
affirmations des gens qui sont lui-même
qui hier nous disait qu'on était pas
besoin de masques qu'ils nous disent qui
a pas de problèmes en matière de liberté
donc les mêmes qui nous ont garanti
qu'ils pouvaient s'occuper efficacement
de notre santé et qu'ils
ont failli en la matière sont en train
de nous dire qu'il faudrait les croire
sur parole quand ils s'occupent de nos
libertés
la sauvette méfiant mais la cnil s'est
prononcée elle a estimé que non stop
covit était conforme aux normes
européennes sur la protection des
données personnelles ce n'est pas
suffisant selon vo non ce n'est pas
suffisant car la portée de la décision
de la cnil est d'abord sujette à caution
alors je vous épargne et de tes pages
critiques de fond mais cette cet avis
n'est qu'un simple avis et qui
correspond d'ailleurs à une application
qui a évolué depuis tu l'avis a été
rendu
donc en tout état de cause on ne saurait
se satisfaire de l'avis de la cnil pour
dire que nous pouvons aller aveuglément
vers cette brèche dans nos libertés
publiques et individuelles parce qu'il
faut voir ce que ça va provoquer
derrière c'est à dire qu'un jour on vous
dit que le traçage est nécessaire pour
combattre une épidémie
le lendemain on va vous dire que c'est
contre le terrorisme depuis contre le
banditisme
puis on va ne s'est fait d'augmenter le
domaine de surveillance des citoyens par
l'intermédiaire d'applications qui vont
le tracé qui vont venir restera tout
simplement leur liberté d'aller et de
venir
c'est à dire qu'un jour on va vous dire
qu'il ya trop de monde sur les routes
pour se rendre d'un point a à un point b
et que par conséquent on n'interdit à
une certaine population de se déplacer
voilà ce vers quoi on se dirige t on
banalise lusage de la traçabilité de nos
concitoyens à le gouvernement français a
refusé de collaborer avec apple ou
google pour élaborer cette application
stop coville est ce que c'est une bonne
chose selon vous de garder nos distances
avec ces géants numériques américain
mais on en revient madame à l usage qui
est fait des données bon alors savoir si
c'est une bonne chose de refuser de
travailler avec google et apple première
conséquence que quand on porte c'est que
ça prouve qu'il n'y a pas de nécessité
absolue
parce que s'il y avait une nécessité
absolue on aurait accepté de collaborer
avec ces deux géants qui aurait accéléré
la mise en place de l'application
donc ça prouve là qu'il y a
des injonctions contradictoires dans la
politique qui est menée à propos de
cette application
la deuxième chose c'est de dire ce qu'on
pense que les données personnelles
seront à l'abri si jamais on ne
travaille pas avec les gars femme c'est
une erreur fondamentale parce que c'est
oublier que les attaques principal sur
les données et les données les plus
sensibles sont le fait non pas des gars
femmes mais des hackers et que par
conséquent les pirates informatiques eux
pourront tout à fait venir mettre à mal
la confidentialité des données merci
beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
répondre à nos questions car bond de 16
avocat au barreau de paille